I didn't just come back to see family.
Lately I've been sensing that there is
something wrong with the speedforce.
I didn't know anyone else was affected
The speedforce is beyond repair.
What did you do?!
Alright, easy peasy.
He
Is
Coming!
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my breakdown of the flash
season 6 episode 14 trailer video Wally
West is back and the Speed Force has
gone completely crazy
what is Barry done now they're
referencing a very specific storyline
because the title of the episode is the
death of the Speed Force and they just
did that in the flash rebirth comics so
I'll explain what that was and how
they're probably going to change that for
the TV show we also got the reverse
flash post-credit scene from last
night's episode with Grodd I'll explain
what's going on with that and the return
of the reverse flash and the idea that
the Dragon Ball Gogeta fusion of Barry
in Grodd is somehow a teaser for the
coming of Red Death eventually since Red
Death is a fusion speedster so if you're
new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get everything we're doing a flash
ring giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
biggest theory about what's going on
with the Speed Force on the video so
starting with the footage first then
I'll talk about Red Death in the reverse
flash post credit scene so Wally West
comes back to visit the flash family
because he hasn't been around in a while
the actor left the show a couple of
seasons ago because he just wanted to go
off and do other things he didn't want
to play Wally West anymore so if you
wonder why Wally West hasn't been on the
flash TV show for a while why he wasn't
part of crisis on Infinite Earths it's
just because the actor left the show and
they didn't have room for him in the
budget because it's really expensive to
do multiple speedsters in episodes kind
of a bummer but at least he's coming
back for this storyline I don't know how
many episodes it's going to last if it's
just going to be this one episode or if
he'll be back a couple times this season
but he says he senses that something
hasn't been right with a Speed Force
since crisis on Infinite Earths ended
since almost everyone including Oliver's
mother Moira queen seemed to have
knowledge of crisis on Infinite Earths
after the merged earth Prime episodes
I'm assuming wally west has a basic
understanding of crisis but maybe he
doesn't totally understand what they did
because they did spend a lot of time in
the Speed Force we got that awesome
scene with the Ezra Miller Justice
League flash crossover well that's a
wait a couple more years for that Blache
movie for them to pay that off they're
still making the flash movie but he's
doing fantastic beasts first so if you
wonder why there is no flash movie yet
that's why because they're doing those
Harry Potter movies also when Wally West
is talking about something not being
right feeling right with the Speed Force
they show you the scene
the fake iris closing the door on the
central city citizen meaning they're
going to continue that plot like team flash
will start to figure out that that's not
the regular iris something during the
episode happens there's this big crime
during jitters that they all go to
investigate cisco and wally west are
there at the crime scene with barry and
joe investigating Cisco whips out one of
his Ghostbusters devices I can't tell
what kind of readings this device is
giving off this looks kind of like a
radioactive simple but without hearing
Cisco's dialogue talking about special
readings you don't really know what it
is that they're measuring here they keep
talking about the Speed Force being all
crazy then they flashed back to the
scene on Lian Yu in the prison where
Barry Speed Force started acting up when
he was getting really upset about all of
her dying but he sort of wrote it off
like some weird glitch and I can't tell
if this is Allegra tackling Nash balls
in a different scene or Cisco tackling
someone just because of the long hair
because it's their stunt doubles
sometimes in trailers you might notice
you can spot the actor stunt doubles
sometimes they'll use the footage from
before they've added the digital face
swapping technology because the actors
won't do the dangerous stunts like if
there's a really big physical fight that
they have to perform it'll be one of the
stunt doubles Barry claims he doesn't
know anyone else was affected he's
probably talking about post-crisis Speed
Force changes he probably starts to
notice more on his own too that
something isn't quite right with the
power sort of teeing up this
conversation with Wally Wally seems like
he's really pissed and says the Speed
Force is beyond repair just completely
losing it then in a different scene
Barry hooks himself up to the Tachyon
enhancer from way back when
reverse-flash helped him design it so
that he could beat zoom back in season
two then they show you the repeat scene
of him when he saw himself dying during
crisis on Infinite Earths just running
running running as fast as he could into
the Speed Force more on that in a second
but I think this is also tangentially
related to the reverse-flash post-credit
scene so there's also the return of God
speed and some Red Death stuff coming up
too so a lot of speedster heavy stuff
happening the back half of the season
for those of you that felt like the
early part of the season was really
speedster light this is sort of that
x-files phenomenon where do they do the
one-off episodes and then the
mythological episodes where they get
into the mythology of the Speed Force
and speedsters those to me tend to be
the more interesting episodes the whole
deal here has been Nash wells
hallucinating the other versions of
Harrison wells from the multiverse
obviously we know the motive
exists because we saw it in that
post-credit scene from crisis on
Infinite Earths part 5 but for whatever
reason none of the other characters know
and Cisco says that the laws of physics
have changed a little bit
so his breaching ability doesn't work
the way it used to so it's not like they
can just breach to another world and see
if everyone's still alive but it seems
like they're implying here is that it's
either the other versions of Harrison
wells connected to Nash wells through
the multiverse somehow through crisis on
Infinite Earths and his abilities as
pariah he supposedly lost them post
crisis but maybe there's some sort of
residual connection to them but it seems
like it's only happening for him in his
mind and when he finally starts
hallucinating Sherlock wells during the
episode and he then turns into reverse
flash saying he is coming the way
they're playing it in this scene is as
if he's having a waking nightmare so
it's only experiencing for him and it's
something that his own mind is
generating like Sherlock wells wasn't a
mean person he wouldn't act like this he
wouldn't be doing this on his own so I
don't think that this is the real
Sherlock wells that's actually telling
him reverse flashes coming
I think it's Nashville's own
consciousness telling him in the form of
Sherlock wells and reverse-flash that
reverse flashes coming but they're
getting really crazy with the mythology
and this isn't necessarily a comic book
storyline that they're doing for
nashville's and reverse-flash so they're
just completely off the page so wide
open to theory crafting the whole idea
with the death of the Speed Force
storyline in the comics though this is
she gets really interesting because it's
a big zoom storyline from the flash
rebirth it involves Wally West and Barry
Allen but it's the ginger version of
Wally West is that the death of the
Speed Force arc starts when Barry and
Wally in this sort of flash war
storyline runs so fast that they break
the Speed Force that's right if it were
even possible to break the Speed Force
they do it and what happens though is
they find that there are other cosmic
forces
besides the Speed Force in the negative
Speed Force that coexist in the same
spaces there's the Speed Force the
negative Speed Force the sage force
which gives people mental powers the
strength Force which gives you increased
strength the still force which controls
entropy and inertia Grodd gains control
over that and then there's the forever
force which gives you control over time
that's the way they explain zooms speed
powers in the comics because in the
comics zoom isn't a speedster he just
moves through the spaces in time
so it appears like he's moving really
fast but really he's just manipulating
the time line but the whole idea is that
when all these other cosmic forces come
into play they start to eat away at the
Speed Force so that's why they call it
the death of the Speed Force and they
had to find a way to get people to stop
using the other cosmic forces but then
Barry becomes the most powerful version
of the flash that he's ever become in
Wally West sort of becomes a new version
of dr. Manhattan for the DC universe
that's kind of what they're calling him
now he's sort of like this cosmic dr.
Manhattan figure just to follow up on
the Red Death questions that I got on my
last episode 13 video because they do
the Dragon Ball Gogeta fusion with Grodd
and Barry coming together a lot of
people were wondering if that's sort of
a set up teaser to explain the concept
for how Red Death can exist on the TV
show because in the comics Red Death is
the fusion of Barry in a version of
Batman who went into the Speed Force
fused then came back out as one being
with Barry's consciousness being trapped
while Batman was controlling the body
we got a teaser for Red Death last
season in season 5 they just mentioned
that the flash had faced red death at
some points so at some point in the
future we would see him so if they're
going to do a comic book accurate version
or as accurate as possible it would have
to be one speedster fused with another
person to become that Red Death
character but the big question was is
who would Barry be fusing with to make
the Red Death character or who would be
the other speedster that someone else
fused with so everyone let me know in
the comments do you think that they're
going to do a version of Red Death that's
going to be a fusion just like we saw a
Grodd and Barry do Dragon Ball style
later this season but if you're
wondering god speed is also coming back
to later this season they'll probably
explain what was going on with him way
back in season 6 episode 1 my initial
assumption is that that would be
something tied to the black hole
storyline because they kind of seemed
like the big bads for the back half of
the season but they also made it seem
like he was traveling back in time so it
has to be someone from the future
manipulating godspeed stuff trying to
send them back in time to fight Barry so
we're kind of back into a time-travel
plot we'll just have to see how it plays
out if we spot any other big Easter eggs
or teasers especially when a Wally comes
back but there's going to be a two-week
break so it's not going to be till March
before we see this episode everyone
click here for all my Avengers infinity
Saga deleted scenes that I
just posted and click here for that
brand-new flash season 6 episode 13
video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay awesome.
I'll see you guys
tonight